hey what's going on it's bill burns time
for the Thursday afternoon just before
Friday Monday morning podcast and I am
just checking in on you that's it you
might notice my voice is a couple
octaves lower I've been doing shows all
this week and I was sick like a month
ago so I don't know that it's [ __ ]
recovered but I don't have my usual
you know mid-range voice but this I
promise you this is me anyways I'm up
here in San Francisco with the north's
theatre with Nate Craig we've been
having a great time all week last night
you know it's one of those nights just
had a great shows I couldn't want to
[ __ ] go home so we ended up going
over to we're just walking around and
ended up just at the Fillmore so we walk
over goes go [ __ ] over there have a
drink or something right because Billy's
off the wagon again right I guess when I
get home we'll get back on the [ __ ]
wagon
I'm the worst I'm either on or I'm off
and I'm sorry by the way if you want to
see arguably some of the funniest [ __ ]
on the internet Nate Craig told me about
Kyle done against Instagram page and I
guess Joe Rogan and Tom Segura those
guys have all hyped it I've been
completely out of the loop
that guy's one of the funniest [ __ ]
comedians I've always been a huge fan of
his stuff and and I thought he was so
[ __ ] original but I I his Instagram
page I can't even describe how [ __ ]
hilarious I was the like every morning
for like the last three days I've been
watching all of his videos for like an
hour just laying in bed crying laughing
his Instagram is at Kyle Dunnigan Kyl
edu nn i GaN hope his felt that right
and then umph number one and he does
like that Face Swap thing and he does
this [ __ ] ridiculous impression of
everybody bill maher Donald Trump
Caitlyn Jenner
all the Kardashians just everything that
he does is [ __ ] is Bill Maher's
ridiculous and then he got like all
these different Trump's he's got tiny
Trump trans Trump just Trump in general
it's [ __ ] unbelievable so check that
out so anyways we ended up walking over
to the landed up over at the Fillmore so
we go to walk in you know and there's a
band playing so of course the security's
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa we're like
yeah hey we're just going in there to
get a drink and the guy goes you can't
there's a show going on this is a
concert venue
you know I taped a special that was kind
of funny I said yeah I know I go I've
performed here because all you've
performed here I've never done this I
just said yeah I'm a comedian I just
want to go and have a drink and then
unfortunately he recognized me and I was
able to pull that [ __ ] card I never
pull that card was pretty cool so then I
went upstairs and I just hear this
[ __ ] woman's voice he's just
incredible playing the guitar incredible
and I poked my head in to see and you
know there was just big tour bus in this
[ __ ] but there wasn't a band onstage it
was just you know you know when the one
person is up there and they're playing
to a loop and then they loop it with
something else the perp you know she was
doing that [ __ ] I was like yeah man I
miss seeing bands I get it all the
[ __ ] crowd stole the music and the
[ __ ] labels through the cross the
board [ __ ] deals will they even take
a piece of your merch you know the
greedy [ __ ] so I get it so I was just
like a so I was kind of bummed out even
though her voice was [ __ ] incredible
it's just like I like watching a live
band cuz I liked when I went up bands
like improvising and [ __ ] I always loved
watching like Stevie Ray Vaughan cuz
you'd see Tommy and Chris Layton
well never stop looking at him because
they're like alright what's he doing is
he gonna go around again or is he gonna
[ __ ] go into the verse you know when
you know and start to come to the point
where he would come out of the solo is
he gonna keep soloing what is he gonna
do and when you just see that he
see Stevie just give him like this
[ __ ] little nod as he's wailing on
the guitar and then they just seamlessly
in that moment know that they're going
to this next sect thats what I [ __ ]
love so it's just one person updates you
know but you're hearing a band I get you
know I'm a [ __ ] old guy where's the
rest of the people right so I walked
into the other room and I was sitting
there with Nate you know and I'm just
listening to this woman singing I'm like
oh my god she's [ __ ] unreal I'm here
a little Amy Winehouse I just she's
incredible and I had a drink or
something and I go man that's I swear to
god that sounds like a band and then I
walked back out there and now there's a
whole band onstage and I'm like where
the [ __ ] did that woman go was she
opening like what the [ __ ] was going on
long story short
I find out it wasn't a woman it was a
guy and his name is Alan stone and it
was one of the [ __ ] best voices I've
ever heard in my life incredible guitar
player we see the name of the band it
was funny we went in there was like like
all these hardcore fans of this band
called Andrew Andrew McMahon in the
wilderness now granted this isn't like
Mike necessarily my style of music that
I would listen to but like how well
these people sang was just it was
[ __ ] incredible
the piano player was cracking me up
because he was dressed like Kenny
Loggins in like the early 80s and like
if you looked at the guy he liked that
guy is gonna have a major cocaine
problem like the Kenny Loggins beard and
then he had the sweater tied around his
neck like when I came up in the 80s
anytime they were gonna have like an
[ __ ] in a [ __ ] coming-of-age movie
in the 80s they always had the sweater
tied around him you know if the [ __ ]
frat boy or whatever but anyways but it
was a completely different vibe and
afterwards all these nerdy chicks were
going out talking look at my faith can
you tell I was crying they were crying
that was definitely I don't know what
was going on but it was definitely sort
of the crowd was those
you know the kids who can't throw a ball
you know and aren't good at fighting it
was that group of people and they were
[ __ ] into this band and this band was
[ __ ] amazing [ __ ] amazing but what
was hilarious
was the bartenders were all bored as
[ __ ] because none of them were drinking
the Fillmore has this really long bar
that goes all the way down the left side
and these [ __ ] bartenders were just
leaning with their backs against you
know where the cash registers and [ __ ]
were but this looks on their face it's
like how the [ __ ] did I get this shift
I'm not gonna make any [ __ ] money
tonight but anyways if you get a chance
to see them live or ever get a chance to
see that Alan stone I just was looking
him up and he was singing with daryl
hall and stuff evidently the guys are
like [ __ ] legendary and I'm going
like who's this chick what where's the
rest of the band and I just walk in the
other room so [ __ ] stupid but I'm
glad that I was able to because I was
talking with people afterwards when they
leave and I go well where was that woman
and they will laughs ago and that wasn't
a woman that was a guy I go that was a
guy
fames Allenstown God anyways so I went
up whenever I saw that there was a whole
bad like I you know I've only been in
the film or a couple times and when
you're upstairs you get you know unless
you have like the two old guys in the
Muppet Show seats and those things it's
very hard to see the band but then this
is one area where it's straight on so
upstairs so I walk and there was this
woman security sit down I go is it okay
to walk over there
and she goes that that section is
private and I wanted to be like I only
asked you once you [ __ ] [ __ ] I don't
she was yelling over the music but it
was just like what the I felt like it
wasn't like a seven-year relationship
with her and whatever the [ __ ] it is
that I do that bugs are I just did it
that section is private
uh you know I thought about you know
who's that guy used to climb in to the
ring like a spider the guy who kicked
the guy and broke his leg in half
Anderson Silva remember that front kick
he would do and you just didn't see it
coming
you know that went into my head she
leaned forward try just give me the old
right there Fred you know and I would do
that as an empowering move to a woman
you know treating her as an equal like
well that's what you would do to a guy
right
how come women don't want that part of
equal rights that's all right you want
to make what we make then you you know
you got to take a mitt to the face every
once in a while by the way I've been
such an [ __ ] on stage this week I've
been having such a good time said some
of the most ridiculous [ __ ] I don't know
that I've said I don't think ever I've
just been like it's a total reaction to
like what the all this [ __ ] crap out
there you know I did this interview
recently I was talking to this guy I'll
probably get in trouble for the shaky
camera what the [ __ ] we were talking
about with the Giger's yeah but you
can't say they can't see it's [ __ ]
yes I can
you can't see what just people all of a
sudden won't know their jokes and then
then there'll be what's gonna what the
[ __ ] is gonna happen
so anyways I've been up here all this
week and I got this thing in my right
eye but if I spend more than one night
someplace they'll bring in some old drum
kit or whatever and I just play on it
during the day so I'm up here and I
don't know the one of the guys who works
at the theater is a drummer and they got
me this sick [ __ ] DW kid it sounds
amazing I brought my double pedal up and
I brought my [ __ ] that all that music
that I wrote out on that Metallica song
she's been having like the best [ __ ]
time ever although I'm missing my wife
or my kid big time but this really is a
an amazing city and I had a friend of
mine come out last night where I had
seen and
Wow I kind of learned some [ __ ] though I
was glad that we hung out there rather
than over at the punchline because I've
really liked how my brain works as far
as when I get depressed is when I try to
go into the past you know like if you go
into a place that you haven't been in a
long time like you're all excited and
then you walk in there and like nobody
that you know you don't know anybody
anymore you like that ah [ __ ] I'm old
the time came and it went
why didn't I enjoy it more you know so
it's glad I met her over there but uh
you know she just was one of the people
I don't know if there should have been a
person like her in every comedy town
because she [ __ ] her taste in
comedians and how much she gave there
still gives a [ __ ] about comedy is why I
think one of the major reasons why the
stand-up scene here has always been so
friggin strong so anyways let's uh let's
plow ahead I went to the Giants game
yesterday the the baseball Giants they
had a day game [ __ ] started at like 1
o'clock and Nate was giving me all this
[ __ ] cuz I was keeping score when I go
to baseball games I like to keep score
cuz if he if I don't I don't know what
the [ __ ] is going on you know there's
literally 18 people you know you don't
know how who's giving up hits you
literally make a pitching change you
don't even hear because there's so much
[ __ ] [ __ ] going on you know that the
Giants they have this woman doing the
[ __ ] announcements and like their
voice just it just doesn't carry like I
don't know what it is like you need the
bass to cut through she's like yeah
she's like what the [ __ ] did she say
then I have to look at the number and
then I got to look it up on my phone so
he just announced it over a PA system
how the [ __ ] did I not hear it I play
drums maybe my ears are [ __ ] up I
don't know I don't know what but um I
got a $12 course at that [ __ ]
ballpark and what was funny is when you
get the score card the score card is a
dollar and then they make you pay for
the pencil now the pencils a buck
like the cheapest thing in the park and
got a bag of peanuts and had an ice-cold
beer I said that keeping schools [ __ ]
grey only thing I was missing was a
cigar would have been perfect and this
[ __ ] guy Suarez got shelled in the
first inning and then he settled down
but the Giants were never able to catch
up it was you know it's a good game it's
definitely good game beautiful ballpark
the Reds got some guy on there on there
their team little fella and he goes by
scooter it's like I'd be like you know
at some point you got to call me by my
name but he still goes by scooter right
so we're sitting they going like Nate's
going out or do you think that guy is
I'm like that guy might be a couple
inches shorter than me and then he steps
up to the plate and just [ __ ] crushes
one crushes one all the way out to the
[ __ ] I call it the ocean mcguffey's
Bay Cove sorry McCovey Cove whatever the
[ __ ] it is I think that's why he still
goes by scooter cuz that's got to really
[ __ ] with the other pitchers you know
confidence me just step up to the plate
you names Mike and you go yard he's not
gonna give a [ __ ] but some guy named
scooter hits the ball into the [ __ ] you
know your best pitch into the [ __ ]
ocean that's good you know you got to be
you got to take a lap you know around
the mouth going like it's just the end
of my career for some [ __ ]
make-a-wish kid just came up and just
[ __ ] crushed into the ocean anyways
how about those Boston Celtics once
again I'm working every [ __ ] night
this week I've missed every second of
the last series in this series I just
keep watching the highlights and in
defense of the Cavaliers I guess they
have the worst team defense in the
league but you know Brad Stevens I guess
is out coaching them and all that stuff
but uh got to be honest with you
I really won't feel comfortable that
we're gonna beat the Cavs until we win
the fourth game because if the Cavs went
tonight I'm assuming the plane tonight
that all of a sudden it's 2-1 and he
just gets scary again like I [ __ ] here
comes LeBron here comes LeBron and when
you're talking about a guy who has led
his teams to the finals how many years
in a row and I don't give a [ __ ] that he
was on a pile
team Kobe was on a pile-on team his
entire [ __ ] career and he didn't go
to the finals [ __ ] you know seven
years in a row whatever the health
LeBron is working on right now so we
shall see this is all you know it's all
gravy but they just keep winning in the
[ __ ] Rockets beat the goddamn
Warriors last night I guess which is
incredible
you just can't root for the Warriors
once Durant went to the Warriors you
just can't [ __ ] really it's just
stupid it's so [ __ ] stupid it makes
the Miami Heat
not look like a pile-on team oh yeah
maybe it was a pilot thing but I'm just
saying you know what I mean
who's the NBA was so fine oh I've said
this a thousand times but the NBA was so
[ __ ] great that Warriors Thunder
series would thunder went up three games
to one and then they [ __ ] it up
because they were too young they didn't
know how to win and the Warriors showed
the championship heart that they had and
then that was the story the next year
was where the Thunder gonna [ __ ] get
over the hump were they gonna dig down
deep and and and slay the [ __ ] dragon
and what happens Luke Skywalker goes you
know what you are my father
I've [ __ ] joined the dark side and
[ __ ] Kevin Durant just goes over
there the second he went over there
everybody who watches NBA hoop goes oh
the Warriors are gonna win the
championship and then they did it was
[ __ ] boring as [ __ ] the only thing I
like about it is that Durant didn't go
to the Lakers and yeah I have to watch
them you know once again free-agent
their way to yet another [ __ ]
championship which admittedly as a
Celtics fan we did in 2008 but the
[ __ ] you know I've watched the Lakers
get five championships in the last like
20 years doing [ __ ] like that and it's
just you know it gets [ __ ] tired
after a while you know especially
because you know according to them
they're one championship behind us which
you know we all know through Bill
Simmons book then not that too and we
also know there was a mobbed-up [ __ ]
ref that fixed that Sacramento series so
they got [ __ ] too bad
you know but what I do like about it is
that's very la to pad your resume you
know to make Instagram videos and then
call yourself a director anyways so I am
I don't know if we'll see what happens I
wish I could just watch one of these
[ __ ] games if we get by the Cavaliers
and the Warriors you know of course
they're gonna go to the [ __ ] finals
how are they not going to win a
championship when you have like every
[ __ ] good guy in the league is on
your goddamn team I mean I don't know
the Celtics actually could win one or
two games against the [ __ ] warriors
on them I'm not looking ahead here I
mean that'd be what I'm real and then we
got Kyrie Irving free agent guy right
there bill [ __ ] hypocrite yeah but
we're upstart dude those are all [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] two everybody adds one
free [ __ ] agent right that's all I'm
saying is but I don't understand why
that one guy couldn't go to the [ __ ]
Lakers but Kevin Durant could go to the
[ __ ] don't stay way did you kill it
be like if when the Celtics beat the
Lakers in 84 if magic said [ __ ] it he
just joined the Celtics I don't know
whatever I'm an old guy
the Celtics side free agents too but I
mean I would I would think if we went to
make a move like that someone was
actually saying that you know Durant or
somebody is up for free agency and he
might go to the Celtics and I was
thinking I don't [ __ ] want that guy I
don't we become part of the problem he's
just gonna bounce around the league no
picking up rings you know and this is
from a guy who barely watches the NBA
why am i this upset I'll tell you why
I'm this upset now that I asked the
question for you for you guys now I'm
gonna answer it I just remember when I
was in you when you were a [ __ ] kid
and you had outdoor recess and you would
choosing up teams even as little kids if
it got too lopsided you'd be like oh
wait a minute wait
you need even it out because even then
you knew like where would the
satisfaction be in winning kids no kids
no not to do what the [ __ ] they're doing
but I mean that is the way it's done now
I mean free agency give I should just
accept the fact okay here's okay here's
the deal
I accept the fact that this free agents
okay and I admit that the Celtics you
know we bought a championship in 2008
and you know and we also added Kyrie
Irving this year but you know maybe you
know him and LeBron could get along a
little better I mean I don't know
[ __ ] no but they asked it should
there should be a line you know that
that Miami Heat things shouldn't have
[ __ ] happen the the what's-his-face
trade Kevin Garnett with Kevin McHale in
the front office gives his old team
Kevin Garnett for nothing that should
have been blocked when Pau Gasol with
Jerry West in the front office went to
Lakers that should have been blocked
just [ __ ] like that that's all I'm
saying see so I took a little burden out
there you know maybe I don't [ __ ]
anyone gives a [ __ ]
so anyways what do I got here I got two
more goddamn sure you have no reach I
have no reach if Thursday and I'm trying
desperately not to do my impression of
countdown against Donald Trump or
[ __ ] Bill Maher through his Bill
Maher is so [ __ ] ridiculously on have
you ever seen the one he does where he
has like Bill Maher reading to children
he's doing reading like weren't nursery
rhymes is like hey diddle diddle the cat
and the fiddle okay the cow jumped over
the moon really over the moon
this story is [ __ ] he just like
makes the kids cry I know I'm doing a
[ __ ] version you got to hear the guy
stop listening my podcasts and go hear
some real comedy at at Kyle Dunnigan one
the guy's a [ __ ] genius I don't get
how that guy is not on Saturday night
life I just don't you know I bet you
know
why cuz they wouldn't do the caitlyn
jenner's [ __ ] i don't know what happened
they they're all [ __ ] political over
there now that used to be rebellious you
know you got to see his caitlyn jenner's
[ __ ] baby trump all it I'm done hyping
it I don't want to [ __ ] over hype it
I can't over height but it's [ __ ]
hilarious
alright plowing ahead here so I got
what's tonight Thursday I got two more
shows up here and then that's the end
I'm gonna be just doing a bunch of sets
around LA getting ready for my Big
Show's they're in in Europe and then my
big birthday turning 50 next [ __ ]
month you know I don't feel any
different
my shoulders [ __ ] great here's the
deal every year my birthday I got to do
like the amount of push-ups for whatever
year I am and I haven't done him the
last couple years because my shoulders
but [ __ ] up so I think the last time I
did him was I turned 47 so I'm up to
doing sets of 35 so I'm right on right
on pace here and maybe then turning 50
won't be as devastating but I did 50
pushups does that make me immortal
anyways you know what I think well the
podcast is gonna be a little short I
mean I don't think I have anything else
to talk about how the [ __ ] am I gonna
fill up these I feel I don't even know
what I mean I'm self-employed why did
why do I feel what am I gonna fire
myself if I know through a full
half-hour is that what it's gonna be hey
you know the Red Sox are actually
playing the Oakland A's I was thinking
of going over there like an [ __ ] you
know what I did here in San Francisco I
was joking I did the impossible I
actually got a [ __ ] sunburn in San
Francisco like the Sun was out but I was
just like it's San Francisco it's always
cold and shitty here they just have
miserable [ __ ] weather that you know
they have the great white shark [ __ ]
weather right the water's freezing no
one ever made it off the rock man right
it's just always like that in fact I
used to always come here and every time
I would come here I'd get
SiC I don't know why it was like the
flight from Newton I was living in New
York and every time I'd come out to do
the punchline I would get sick because I
wasn't taking care of myself
then I had that extra long flight and
then I would step off into this just
cold damp [ __ ] awful weather and like
three times in a row when I came here I
got sick and Molly at the punchline I
remember the last time I came out there
she sent me like [ __ ] sent me all
these vitamins C packages just [ __ ]
drinking a zillion of them before I got
out there so I wouldn't get sick I
started to think I was allergic to this
doubt so when I looked you know I looked
up the [ __ ] weather coming up here as
I was waiting for it to pop up I just
said cold and shitty and I looked at and
it was every day there was clouds with a
little bit of Sun and then rain and I
don't know what happened something
changed so yesterday we we walked over
to the ballpark and I'm like god this is
gonna burn off this is gonna burn off I
bought a couple of really good seats and
I was just sitting in the Sun the whole
[ __ ] time wearing a North Face jacket
sweating my ass off but I was like oh I
can't take this off because I got on
short sleeves underneath it I'm gonna
[ __ ] burn up so I sat there in a
winter coat in like 75 degree weather
keeping score I look like a [ __ ] you
know the only always missing was those
giant headphones with like the AM radio
antenna sticking out of it
those are the [ __ ] lunatics though
like I wasn't that bad of a nerd you
know those guys who actually listen to
the ballgame while they're watching it
and they're keeping score but I'll tell
you they know everything that's going on
they know when they make a pitching
change when there's a pinch-hitter and
all of that [ __ ] like trying to keep
score like when you're out in the
outfield the only way I was able to do
it because I was and right behind home
plate so when somebody came up on on
deck I would just check the number to
make sure they didn't switch somebody
out and that's my exciting story about
keeping score
alright I'm finished I'm starving I'm
gonna go on I've been eating good even
though I've been drinking again which I
don't [ __ ] like but I just can't I
get [ __ ] bored when I'm out here what
am I gonna do you don't know [ __ ] me up
was I brought my rosetta stone up here I
brought the little external [ __ ] dis
thing that you stick it in I plug it in
and I left the [ __ ] disk at home so
now what am I supposed to do am I
supposed to get some [ __ ] a coloring
book my shows are at 7 every night I'm
done by 9 I'm all wound up you know I've
seen more goddamn couples arguing in
public up here the city is more
expensive I guess than even New York
City for rent or to buy something and
you can really see the stress on the
people just screaming at each other saw
that three times yesterday and I'll tell
you the woman was winning all three and
each one of these relationships I was
like she's a lot smarter than that guy
why is she with this person because like
the guy was like trying to come back you
know like the Rocky Balboa what about
you the woman were just Bratley off all
the things that this guy was [ __ ] up
a granite I was just walking by you know
I experienced their relationship for
five seconds and my immediate thought
other than these two people need to
break up was you know she's got you that
buddy she's making a lot of good points
[Laughter]
and I've been joking about this on stage
too San Francisco has the most homeless
homeless people I've ever seen in my
life it's almost like they're not real
they're so [ __ ] homeless they're Skid
Row it's just [ __ ] it's unbelievable
we walked by this woman she was
literally passed out and her hand was on
the ground and there was an empty bottle
of booze that like so artistically had
just rolled like like two and a half
inches of
from her hand it looked like you were
you yeah like you won the set of a movie
about homeless people like that that's
just such a perfect shot you know about
alcoholism and addiction and all of that
type of [ __ ] but it's like real you know
we were like walking home from the park
trying to avoid the hills you know as
much as we could and we just got into
this this it was like you know
everybody's got this Skid Row they have
a neighborhood just a [ __ ] name he's
walking through you know I saw this
[ __ ] guy he's in a wheelchair when
these guys in a wheelchair but his legs
work whatever the [ __ ] that deal is you
know and he just had like his shirt
pulled up over his face and then his
hands like covering his face like he was
the saddest person on the planet you
know I was walking on with a film or and
there's this blind guy just asking
people somebody can help him cross the
street so I was like all right I'm going
that way you know and then he grabs my
arm and then I immediately put my hand
on my wallet cuz it's like all right I
know I'm a gullible white guy but I'm
not that [ __ ] dumb all right so I go
to step off the curb and he goes wait
wait wait wait wait and I was like oh
yeah you're right it's [ __ ] green and
then I'm looking at him like I start
laughing like how the [ __ ] did you know
that that light was great and he started
laughs and I forget what the [ __ ] I
guess it makes a noise or some [ __ ] like
that but I almost walked a blind guy he
goes you got to watch out for the busses
I always walk the blind guy right earth
right into the [ __ ] bus so I'm a
[ __ ] liberal SAP you know this woman
says to me can you give me a blob of
blood she look all sad and Joseph some
way she [ __ ] asked me I was like I
give us some money and I said Nate you
think she's drinking and he goes yeah
and I was I was like I forget it I won't
[ __ ] and he goes look if you want to
go buy her a sandwich I'll [ __ ] do
that and I was like all right all right
you know well maybe she needs some
[ __ ] booze I got a phone call
oh look who it is look who it is
an old friend of the podcast Joe DeRosa
Joe I got you on speaker
I'm record wrapping up Joe Joe remember
we used to do one in forum remember we
used to when are we ever gonna do
another episode of anything was that
plural or was it just was that one fan
or did you actually say fans there was a
fan after I opened for you and uh what
was in Atlanta people came up to me
after the show outside what are you
doing I was like you know what's [ __ ]
hilarious about all of this [ __ ] Joe if
I jumped in my car how quickly would I
get to your apartment with no traffic
[Laughter]
with no traffic Joe I gotta be honest
with you I have the weirdest
relationship with you on all of my
friends because we never had a falling
out but how little we see each other and
how close we live together it's like we
had a falling-out I don't know what
happened what happened to us Joe family
back east all right well I think there's
a reason why you're called so I guess we
got to do something we got it we got at
least I got to have you on the podcast
as a guest is there anything you want to
promote Joe
they'll have a podcast of my own but
we'll see you with hell Joe oh it's okay
it's about that was like Jesus Joe he
said it's about horror movie star at I
talked over him you gonna shake your ass
up there in Northern California making
you money alright let me end this
[ __ ] podcast hang on one second all
right no no I'll talk to you about what
other [ __ ] you want to talk about it
right hey by the way I've you know not
wait now stay on first say hey have you
gone to kyle done it have you been on
kyle done against instagram page dude
it's it's the funniest [ __ ] you have to
go on it it's some of the funniest [ __ ]
i've seen on the [ __ ] Internet I'm
not threatening you Joe I'm just saying
you got to do it alright let me wrap up
this podcast don't [ __ ] hang up cuz
you won't pick up you know you never
pick up unless it's a broad there all
right that's that's the Thursday
afternoon podcast I gotta talk to my my
[ __ ] stepbrother Joe DeRosa here
enjoy the music and the Thursday
afternoon just before Friday Greatest
Hits that will follow here alright I'll
check it on you on Monday you [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm out of my [ __ ] mind do like when
I'm out here I really had to make a rule
about just relaxing when I Drive and one
thing that I helped is very therapeutic
for me is letting people go right if
you're really like and I get so
frustrated with the quality of the
driving out here the inability to
[ __ ] make turns at a decent speed and
and will do when they go by [ __ ] out
here the second they pass it it's it
they don't even remember it they have no
if there's no [ __ ] clue as for what's
behind you like you know what they do
here out here that [ __ ] drives me not
you'll be sitting behind some guy at a
red light you know and you're up on his
bumper you know like you're supposed to
be nothing crazy and if the light turns
green he then puts his ax left [ __ ]
directional light it's absolute enraging
and it's self centered and yeah it's
it's it's I'm with you it's wrong that I
fantasize about pushing him into traffic
and no it's wrong you don't have the
moral courage to do it totally right and
whenever you hear about someone getting
shot and killed for road rage everyone
first goes oh my god that maniac that
shot that person and I honest to god the
first thing I think is I'm glad like
until I find out the guy with the gun
was the dick right who [ __ ] up first I
love that you have to find out that the
guy with the gun was a dick I know to
find out till I find out the guy with a
gun overreacted a little something about
because people are so self-centered and
narcissistic when they drive it's a
reflection of who they really are so
that's why we take it so [ __ ]
personally merely let you let people go
if the guy if a guy doesn't wave thank
you to me don't do that I will sin they
don't do that out here and I go from
like being this [ __ ] mother Teresa
person I turn into the devil it starts I
try to stay calm it starts with a couple
of rallies in my car I just go really
really really you're not gonna [ __ ]
these [ __ ] people out of here I end
up turning into that just because some
douche dude do you see the look on their
face they're like please please please
let me go and you go to let him go and
you think like oh hey
thumbs up something nothing they
immediately are just back
into their own I don't know I find
sometimes I wave at people out here and
they look at me like weird like what do
you know me like maybe you know I did
move 2500 miles away from where I
learned you know societal rules so maybe
uh but you know you just think if you
know if you're waving to another white
guy I mean we're pretty [ __ ] generic
yeah you know there's not a lot of depth
to the culture here there's no black
guys a little freaked out
well plus East Coast though it's so
aggressive and I hate to do like you
know anything but I'm here maybe that
courtesy like you know in Boston or New
York if someone lets you cut it it's
like hey [ __ ] I did you occur to
sing okay thank you for the courtesy
yeah you're a good [ __ ] though welcome
you're welcome but here it's like well
that was just expected because they
might do that for each other more out
here not a big deal that's the only I
can think of I was on the Pennsylvania
Turnpike one time driving to a gig I
know I'm popping all over I'm very
self-conscious talking to no you don't
know much credit but I don't have I
don't have anybody to help us out with
this okay I was driving to a gig
and a guy cut into my lane I was doing
about 70 was raining and he had normal
and I'm like I'm hydroplaning you know
it was a real drive to it my Mustang no
punkers [ __ ] [ __ ] hydroplane Carter
call and I'm driving and and this guys
coming to my lane and I immediately your
mind when you think you're gonna die
goes very quickly and I'm like okay you
gotta slam on the brakes you're gonna
have an accident hit the wall like it
try to it's been a smart yes let's slow
self down sideswiped the wall so I jam
on the brake I hit the horn and he beers
out and we don't have the accident so
then I'm not afraid I'm in a rage at
this [ __ ] guy right and I pull up
next to him and it's a it's a you know
the fat black dude like an old family
mopey guy and I'm ready to really you
know Cleveland from Family Guy
actually yes Williams even that was
never common and he looks at me and he
gives me the like oops
I [ __ ] up ways up sorry it gives me
that and every bit of anger do you can't
cuz he just owned up to it I'm sorry I'm
sorry
yet I waved back no problem yeah that
was this in a second my raid you know
it's funny I sometimes when somebody
acts on the rage even though I know it's
wrong
I sort of lived through the the [ __ ]
ecstasy that that must be like do you
remember when Russell Crowe through the
fall yes that guy I just can't imagine
like when you're in a hotel and you're
not getting the customer service you
want on whatever it is that the fact
that you actually take the machine that
they won't help you with and [ __ ]
hurt somebody the person who's not
helping you you [ __ ] hurt him with it
yeah completely wrong thing to do but I
can't imagine I always was wondering why
quite as he's letting that phone go just
just [ __ ] all that rage going at him
I think it was it was good for him was
bad for the guy behind the by the
counter on account was bad two people
learned a lesson that day Russell Crowe
learned not to do it the other guy
learned better [ __ ] customer service
next time because I remember when that
happened I was in the Greenwich Hotel in
which DeNiro owns and I remember he's
like oh my god it's a really nice place
it's beautiful like he would stay at a
dive when a stupid comment but I
remember thinking the satisfaction it
must have felt when the phone hit the
guy like how good that must have felt to
throw that phone at that [ __ ]
and again he got in big trouble for that
but yeah that was a story that if you
know how mad you are you you're pulling
the wires out of the wall and that voice
is still not going okay what are you
doing what are you doing and then you
wrap it up you leave your hotel you're
walking down the hall you leave your
room you get into the [ __ ] elevator
and your brain still going yeah throw it
at him yeah throw that what happened
well I mean he went downstairs to the
front I mean I don't
I was just when he picked the phone up
off the desk and just threw them all I
thought he was upstairs in his room
maybe he was but I thought the I didn't
I didn't I thought he just picked the
phone up and threw it the guy that makes
way more sense I find out that he
actually wrapped the cord and took the
phone from downstairs that makes me love
him more I was
I loved him just for picking it up I
probably [ __ ] it up I [ __ ] up
everything I don't know do you know the
other day I actually called the periodic
chart I called it the periodical yeah
but that's understand I mean once I was
on Breaking Bad it's no excuse
it's like you're on if you're on a
Western you call it a cowboy head
how do you not [ __ ] know it shows you
them on a [ __ ] research I did
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
this is the Monday morning podcast from
Monday May 17th 2010 how the hell are
you how you doing how's your workweek
yeah yeah I just this is one of these
days right where I should I should you
know something I'm gonna start having
Tapout days where I don't do the [ __ ]
podcast because I just got off a goddamn
flight and I am [ __ ] exhausted once
again I flew across this goddamn country
and once again it was a usual [ __ ] you
know and I don't want to make fun of
people who are out of shape because I
got a really heartfelt letter from
somebody who was obese saying what the
[ __ ] why he always trash and fat people
which I'm not that's all you're hearing
because that's the one that pulls on you
your your heartstrings you know when he
writes the whole [ __ ] thing about how
blah blah blah blah bluh bluh bluh yada
yada yada all this [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
you know everybody feels everybody
whatever group they're in they feel like
they get it the worst you know we get it
the worst you know even bla bla bla when
they blue blue
people we shake I gather yeah right but
when they say [ __ ] I know please all
right
everybody thinks they got it the worst
and only one person is right okay so you
got like a [ __ ] 85% chance of being
wrong
you know nobody says uh you know I'm
gonna beat you like an obese stepchild
do they they don't they say I'm gonna
beat you like a redheaded stepchild
they don't have kick a fat guy day do
they they have kick a [ __ ] redhead
day a gingered day right that's what
they have
am i a didn't make a [ __ ] video about
the the [ __ ] genocide of obese people
did she
no she didn't she made it a redheads and
it was funny even a me I've been so
beaten down as a [ __ ] redhead alright
so quit your [ __ ] whining you know
it's a [ __ ] podcast I trash everybody
everybody's going down including myself
everybody goes down this week okay my
Bruins are gonna lose four games in a
[ __ ] row and I gotta listen to Keith
Robinson
okay a guy who my entire time of knowing
him every time I try to bring up hog he
goes out hawkish stinks I don't like it
nobody cares about hockey all of a
sudden he gives a [ __ ] you know what's
funny about that [ __ ] ignorant
jackass
he wouldn't even unknown that the Bruins
had a historical collapse of you know
I'm so stupid of historical proportions
he wouldn't even unknown it's just that
ESPN finally showed some [ __ ] hockey
Jesus Christ I was in Boston when it
happened and I really want to tell
Philly people that everybody was
devastated but I gotta be honest with
you I think maybe 11% of the city gave a
[ __ ] and I'll tell you why because we
haven't won in 38 [ __ ] years and
we've pretty much sucked
the Bruins kind of jumped the shark when
Ray Bourque had to leave the team so
he'd have an opportunity to win and then
he went out to Colorado won the Cup and
then I know he will you meant this in a
good way he brought the cup to the city
to remind everybody in Boston what it
looked like and that was a low point you
know that was a low point and then we
were up three games to one against the
Canadiens and we couldn't close him out
we lost that [ __ ] series then they
blew up the team and they trade away
gone shy and [ __ ] joke Thornton dude
[ __ ] him the couple of quiz they leaders
dude so we trade away our best [ __ ]
guys for what who do we get we got the
[ __ ] babyface Magoo who we ended up
trading to [ __ ] Toronto that's the
only thing I got I got right now we got
the number one pick for Phil [ __ ]
Kessel that's all I got right now but
anyways I don't know what happened in
that series all of a sudden they just
they just [ __ ] sucked
it wasn't like they weren't even trying
they weren't even [ __ ] they were just
standing there going wow look at the fly
Jesus Christ can that guy skate oh hang
on a second I'm gonna try to clear it
out of the zone and the guy would take a
slap shot and he couldn't get it he
couldn't even clear it out of the
[ __ ] zone it would go like sideways
into the boards Jesus Christ and now my
god that [ __ ] Mac Davis looking
jackass Hartnell whatever the [ __ ] his
name is he was funny but Hartnell is
after the game when he's not when he's
not wearing a helmet he looks like a
scary son of a [ __ ] like Jesus Christ
did that guy just come out of the woods
you know does it does dust you know even
[ __ ] he just he just looks like I
don't know what he looks like he looks
like a mountain man he puts that of that
helmet on all of a sudden he looks like
he's in blades of glory you know any
[ __ ] guy can't even skate every day
every time he goes I make a pass he
falls down but the [ __ ] there though
tapping it in Danny Briere all those
[ __ ] [ __ ] congratulations Phil
you guys totally deserve it you know
unlike the Bruins you didn't quit you
kept playing the game and I don't know
what happened actually the Bruins played
the game right through Game four and
they played the first period of Game
seven and a little bit of the third
period you know and I know this sounds
like I'm taking away from the Flyers but
dude they were just standing there and
they had one line that would actually go
out and start checking some of the
Flyers and when they did all of a sudden
we were getting we were getting
opportunities and it's like why wouldn't
you continue doing that was is that
crazy when not yet another job crazy had
on the bench did he also sit on the
bench go oh yeah guys by the way don't
forget to play hockey when you're out
there and when they're when they're
around our net and they have the puck
it's usually a good thing to try to you
know disrupt them trying to put it into
the net rather than just standing there
and waiting for them to shoot it in the
neck into the net so you then can whack
your stick on the ice and frustration Oh
jeepers they did it again golly gee gee
whiz I was [ __ ] brutal was bad enough
I had to sit there and watch the Bruins
lose but I was in
which means this is a great thing about
[ __ ] being in Boston is you guys know
I feel about Dan Shaughnessy okay the
guy he knows baseball
I'll give you know I will give him that
but other than that he has made a
[ __ ] career on misery the guy loves
misery there's any [ __ ] misery to be
found I don't give a [ __ ] if somebody's
playing highlight or stickball he's
gonna be there to write a [ __ ] story
and the great thing is is he doesn't
have the decency to know a goddamn thing
about the sport all he's got to do is
just talk about this misery that's about
ready to happen or is happening and then
somehow tie it in to [ __ ] Game six of
the 1986 Red Sox Mets series that's what
the [ __ ] he did with hockey
if anybody who lives in Boston still has
I was gonna grab one of the globes
Boston Globe's it's [ __ ] hilarious I
was saying it the night when we lost and
I was in a bar with like eight other
people it was more [ __ ] flat screens
on than there were [ __ ] Bruins fans
at that point right typical of all
cities dude I've been diehard I'm and I
everybody's [ __ ] Dyer when they win a
championship all of a sudden they [ __ ]
the bed four games in a row you know
dude I'm kind of into the Celtics coming
to the Celtics of course you are you
like a winner don't you but I was little
Santa going you watch this guy he'll
somehow you know he'll bring it around
to the curse of the babe which of course
he does and the great thing is is he
does not know [ __ ] about hockey all he
did was he looked at the box score to
see who scored win just so he could be
and at 1748 of the second period when a
[ __ ] Hartnell shot the puck and then
that dancing he could then be like it
was quieter in the in the garden than it
was in Fenway back in [ __ ] poppy with
Mookie Wilson
he guys the worst he's the [ __ ] worst
and he's got he just I don't know I just
don't understand how that guy still has
a job and why people in Boston continue
to buy his books about [ __ ] misery
you know he's such a [ __ ] anytime
anything remotely bad starts to happen
in Boston
sports he always got oh my god what's
gonna happen it's really is that how you
[ __ ] approach you know whatever the
[ __ ] word is for adversity adversity
that's the word that's how you approach
it it isn't you wouldn't have got to the
level that you're at as a sports writer
and being on ESPN if that's how you
approach adversity so stop - you don't
use your [ __ ] lazy learn about the
goddamn game before you write another
one your lazy ass [ __ ] articles Dan
Shaughnessy you want to see what this
guy looks like I'll tell you right now
just go go to [ __ ] the mm podcast.com
got a nice [ __ ] photo put up a him
this week that noodled hair looking
jackass do you know I remember I like a
year after the Red Sox after they came
back being down four games to none you
know not against some sad sack [ __ ]
team that barely met made the goddamn
playoffs it doesn't have a [ __ ] score
they came back against a 210 to $1
[ __ ] team with like four or five
first-ballot Hall of Famers we go on and
and win the goddamn World Series the
very next year in September we got a
couple of injuries we have like a six or
seven game lead against the Yankees and
all of a sudden the Yankees come on and
we start to lose a little bit and this
[ __ ] idiot writes the curse is back
you can feel it it's back it's in the
water you know it's the curse of what
Dan the curse of what 2004 the what off
the [ __ ] a let 11-month curse the
curse of what that no one wants to buy
your stupid [ __ ] book about misery is
that what it is I don't know that I got
a mint I think that was the worst part
about the Bruins losing four games and
Rochas for the [ __ ] life of me I
still don't hate the Flyers I actually
like car silho I really like him and I
hate the [ __ ] Canadians I hate the
Canadians you know if a flyer fan gave
me [ __ ] I mean I I just sit there and
take it
Canadian fare gave me [ __ ] I'm not gonna
take it because I'll tell you at the end
of the [ __ ] day that flyer
fan he's from the United States that's a
fellow-countryman so all he's gonna do
is Trash the Bruins
he's not gonna trash the good old USA
that's why I don't like the kanay that's
why I hate the Canadians fans the most
they [ __ ] trash my team and my country
I'll tell you right now I won't stand
for it with their little pointy little
French noses their pointy little French
noses huh talking about yesteryear
I'll walking around with their high
school [ __ ] letterman jackets about
how they used to dominate the league
thirty [ __ ] years ago
let me tell you something right now
Canadians you guys can [ __ ] slide all
over the ice blocking as many shots as
you like because your goaltender
actually sucks he's any [ __ ] good
while you guys flopping around like a
bunch of goddamn flounders every time
someone takes a [ __ ] wrist shot oh my
god whatever am I really trashing teams
that are still in it I'm gonna shut the
[ __ ] up now what am I gonna do okay what
goes around comes around I've talked a
lot of [ __ ] my teams have won a bunch of
championships we deserve some sort of
you know it's the balance Dan
Shaughnessy it's the balance okay he
can't win all those [ __ ]
championships in five years and not
expect to get kicked in the seeds as a
sports fan all right but do me a [ __ ]
favor don't write any more articles
about hockey cuz you don't know a
[ __ ] thing about it with you glancing
at the box score curse of the babe
horseshit that you wrote they should
surround this unit they should do with
all those globes though that piece of
[ __ ] article he wrote they should snip
it all out tie him to a stake and use
that as stuff that you used to start a
fire whatever that word is what is that
word come on help me out here that word
to use when you stoke a fire with
something gives with a K doesn't Kindle
in a kit kettle in our [ __ ] something I
don't either [ __ ] it is Jesus Christ I
know I don't you know if you gave me a
three games to none lead with like
[ __ ] six of my friends I used to play
pond hockey with we could have won one
[ __ ] game Jesus Christ just [ __ ]
standing around
standing around then they went up three
games three goals to none in Game seven
and then all of a sudden they score the
Flyers score one goal and then they go
back to that [ __ ] hockey again oh yeah
he's good to go do you think they're
gonna score another one it was it was
pathetic and I don't know I am ashamed I
am ashamed I'm ashamed of my team but I
still love him and I'm still wearing my
Bruin [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ] you know
who gives a [ __ ] lose three games in a
row four games in a row yeah why would
you give a [ __ ] you know you know I know
I like how these idiots are sitting
there talking about hockey right now
going like you know it's wide open this
year it's [ __ ] wide open you know
though number 1 C 2 C 3 C 4 C his [ __ ]
gone yeah that's because the two teams
that are left beat those teams stupid
all right
why shouldn't L the Bruins beat the
[ __ ] third seat whatever I'm just
saying
and all of a sudden people doing with
the Canadiens like they'd like there's
still an eighth seed team they are still
an eighth seed team but you know they
beat the Capitals and the Penguins so I
would have to think that they are odds
on favorites to win it and I know this
is boring the [ __ ] out of everybody I've
literally talked about hockey for 15
[ __ ] minutes have I [ __ ] you guys I
don't give a [ __ ] all right in this next
round I am for the Blackhawks and I am
for and I am for the Flyers my nightmare
finals obviously is the Canadiens for
San Jose because I hate both of those
teams
I respect San Jose I went there they're
actually it's a hockey town they [ __ ]
love that team even even though they
[ __ ] choke every year but I got I
just don't like how they you know they
annoy me San Jose you know and they
annoy me because they remind me of how
annoying my friend um how my franchise
never [ __ ] signs anybody they somehow
sign everybody in there under
[ __ ] cap but I got to go for the
Blackhawks because they haven't won it
since 61 and so I'm pulling for that
team and and then I got a pole for the
Flyers because I don't know I actually
always have liked the Flyers so I have
to a minute I just always liked them
I like the fights back in the [ __ ]
day oh and speaking of that I remember
that [ __ ] before the series started dig
they got this new show on the vs.
Network this roundtable of like four
regular dudes and then I have like some
big sports star come on I'm not saying
if it's a good show a bad show but I saw
somebody on I believe it was that show
going like Bruins verse flyers uh god
this is gonna be a bloodbath okay just
for the [ __ ] record for people who
don't [ __ ] watch hockey it's not 1979
anymore alright and the Bruins at Flyers
just played seven games seven games I
believe two of which that went into
overtime I'm already trying to block the
whole memory of that series out and
there wasn't one [ __ ] fight there
wasn't even at any cheap shot there was
I can't remember I don't what I mean I
wasn't really paying attention with the
Bruins anyone at one point Mac Davis
there got got a stick to his face best
because the dude was trying to lift his
stick up and he missed it
you know he got a couple of [ __ ]
stitches [ __ ] alright that's it there I
addressed it so uh I don't know whatever
I heard there's a really good guy in the
draft next year Taylor Hawkins has that
his name is that the drummer from the
Foo Fighters I can't [ __ ] remember I
don't know any of that [ __ ] I'm just
hoping look this is all I wanted all I
wanted was us to [ __ ] after we beat
the the [ __ ] sabers just have a good
showing in the next round II don't we
[ __ ] lose I don't care I know we're
rebuilding but did you have to [ __ ] the
bed to that [ __ ] level alright
whatever this is the Monday morning
podcast this is a special hockey edition
of the the Monday morning podcast all
right [ __ ] to go from here how about a
YouTube video I I might even hype this
thing last week this is one of these
things just
search this don't fall asleep at a
baseball game just watch that and for
all you women out there you'll realize
how much fun it is to be a guy when you
watch this video like we can have fun
when there is absolutely nothing going
on and not only that it's [ __ ]
hilarious are you saying that we can't
have fun actually I think I kind of am
but I think the reality is is I just
don't understand your fun so I want I
will let this fall you all the ladies
out there why don't you watch that video
okay and I challenge you not to [ __ ]
laugh well I guess you won't you won't
laugh you guys are great liars and
you're great at controlling your [ __ ]
emotions so you won't but I'm just
telling you it's a funny [ __ ] video
all right now you then and if you want
to show me how women have fun you show
me a video of women doing like
absolutely nothing is going on but it's
still [ __ ] hilarious find one of
those on YouTube and I'll have a little
more respect for whatever it is that you
do because my references are I guess Sex
in the City you know is that even a
reference I don't know just the women
I've dated I've always watched that
[ __ ] show you know can you believe
they make it another [ __ ] one of
those movies they're making another Sex
in the City movie and now they're going
to Egypt at what point are they just
gonna let that [ __ ] thing die why
don't they just have the cast of The
Drew Carey Show show up and that's what
they should do and then turn it into
Caligula and somebody gets fisted and
then just [ __ ] end it could somebody
just end this really has nothing to do
with either one of those franchises it
has to do with my [ __ ] jet lag and in
the Bruins complete [ __ ] collapse
[Laughter]
alright you know I drank a lot this past
week this is this is I'd realized
something this is a big test in a
relationship I don't give a [ __ ] how
beautiful you think a woman is how much
you love her how much she makes her
heart go pitter-patter your heart go
pitter-patter the the true test of
whether or not you can stand you're
gonna be able to stand
the woman that you think you're gonna
spend the rest of your life with is if
you can handle what her voice sounds
like when she's trying to yell over the
noise in a bar if you can handle what
that sounds like and you just fill in
your funny punch line right there
because evidently I don't have the
[ __ ] energy to do it whatever I just
talked for hockey for 17 minutes to my
[ __ ] self I trashed Dan Shaughnessy I
told the fat guy to stand down you know
[ __ ] people want sympathy because
they always eat the last cookie really
selfish sons of [ __ ] all right you
know what I'm gonna do this week I'm
gonna tap out by reading some [ __ ]
emails from some of my listeners well
here's something I learned this week did
you know that when the natural color of
rubber is white did you know that I
didn't know that went by this guy's
place he had this collection of [ __ ]
cars and old motorcycles and I love that
[ __ ]
because I wish I was good at working on
cars you know what I mean but I wish I
had a set of wrenches I'm working on a
car you know greasy rag in my back
pocket I could [ __ ] you know find
that right spot on the jukebox and make
it play a song you know but I can't you
know I kill ya you know what [ __ ] you I
could I could if I took some time I
watched a couple YouTube videos and he
gave me a regular old engine I could do
some [ __ ] I could figure out some stuff
maybe in another life I don't know what
so anyways this guy had an old
motorcycle guy like how it's gotta you
know all white tires on it and he goes
that's actually because it was like a
one of the original motorcycles I guess
well you couldn't even [ __ ] stop the
thing it just had to run out of gas you
just turned it on and it just went full
on and I guess the way to slow it down
was you had to reach down and put your
hand over the carburetor or something
whatever the [ __ ] yeah where the air
goes in the old is that what happens
oxygen and gas mixture he just put it
over there you sort of smothered it and
that's how you slowed it down but
anyways these tires I know that's
completely wrong so you [ __ ] gear
heads can trash me I don't give a [ __ ]
you doing a podcast you got a podcast on
how the original motorcycles
run I didn't think you did so go [ __ ]
yourself all right don't you clean out
under your nails so your wife doesn't
get another [ __ ] infection that was
brutal
um anyways when your finger blaster just
to spell it out to the [ __ ] nerds and
the cubicles um how do I know that I
forget how I know that I overheard a
[ __ ] dirty broad talking about that
in a bar one night anyways yeah I guess
the original color of rubber and its
natural color is white I didn't know
that so all these years when I was
looking at white wall tires I thought
that they just took like a strip of
white paint or whatever and they painted
in white and the natural color of rubber
was black but it is white and you would
think I would have noticed you know all
the years of looking at cars that
sideswiped curbs you know and hacking up
their tires it was always white
underneath you think that I would have
noticed but I never did so here's my
question for all you gearheads out there
why do they paint it black you know
anybody where am I going with this [ __ ]
you know what that actually reminds me
of you ever see like when somebody dies
on a bicycle and then they have that
entire ghost white bicycle that they
have there that creepy one with the
flowers I saw another one it absolutely
gives me [ __ ] chills
it's my closest sixth sense moment that
I'll ever have in my life when they do
that I don't for the [ __ ] life of me
understand why they have to put the bike
there too you just can't put a wreath
down why do they have to do the whole
bike what is who started that I know I
talked about this on the Opie and
Anthony show a couple years ago but what
the [ __ ] it still bugs me it just creeps
me out that you know he was on a bike
and he died they don't have like drunk
drivers you don't they smash into trees
or you get hit by a drunk driver do they
Frost out a [ __ ] car you know with a
mannequin underneath it I it's a brutal
joke but I you know what I mean it's
just [ __ ] creepy [ __ ] creepy stop
it
Cimino gets hit on a bicycle leave a
wreath there like a normal person
[ __ ] sit down once she just put the
bike he got hit on with the bent up
tires and [ __ ] I knew it was gonna be
mean this week I'm tired and I'm [ __ ]
my Bruins lost four in a row all right
let me try to get something positive
here I'm literally in Mayday Mayday
right now all right hi bill my fiance
and a couple of our friends saw you in
Atlantic City this past Saturday you
would be on hysterical I got a picture
with you I recently quit my job as a
photo retoucher for this high-end
retouching company like my job was to
make models thinner and more beautiful
but also sit on my ass 10 to 12 hours
per day like a robot it was brutal but
what could help me through it was
listening to your Monday morning podcast
I would sit there in a silent room
hysterically laughing often needing to
throw my headphones off because I was
crying I was laughing so hard in fact I
got in trouble once for laughing so much
I needed to be more and people told me I
need to be more serious about my job for
thanks so thanks for doing what you do
well thank you I don't know why I saved
that podcast but that email made me feel
good and you know what I saved that
before the Bruins lost four games in a
[ __ ] row so I was I was in a better
mood all right let's read another one
see if I can get out of this I'm really
really bombing right now bill hi I love
your work I don't know if you've covered
this before as I found out about you
what do you views on celebrity adoption
I think I saw Sandra Bullock's has just
done this but to be honest she doesn't
have the profile or in or indeed now the
father figure to really pull off this
adoption seriously though I think it's
sick they find the most fashionably
deprived countries countries oh my god I
can't even read this week - all right
bill come on come on get your [ __ ]
together right they find the most
fashionably deprived countries that
doesn't even make sense you mean the
most popular ones to give a [ __ ] about
is that what you mean
they take the prettiest kid in the
orphanage and then dress them up at the
babyGap and carry them around like a
[ __ ] Chihuahua it's like by absorbing
them into this plastic
la [ __ ] lifestyle they pretend
they're actually doing something about
the root cause of global poverty when
Angelina Jolie adopts a 56 year old
Serbian war widow with a drinking
problem
takes her to Disney World and lets her
[ __ ] Brad Pitt I might then buy it all
right that's all hilarious even though I
didn't read it correctly but you know
this is just this classic thing where do
you ever notice when you do something
good if people find out about it they
have to trash it on some level I mean
you know I get what you say and I've
actually done bits about that you know
that they you know I actually did some
about Paris Hilton something but
dazzling some African kid making her
making the kid match her phone or
something like that she left it behind
in a club was one of those topical jokes
I don't think I ever did on TV but she
is kind of doing something about pucker
you say she's not doing something about
poverty she just took a kid who was in
poverty all right I'm gonna play the
devil's advocate okay and put him in a
[ __ ] house with running water and is
now gonna feed him you know I think a
lot of times when people do good [ __ ]
like this it annoys people because it
reminds us that we're not doing [ __ ]
about it maybe that's why I make fun of
them or maybe it's that thing you know
heathens pray in public so everybody can
see how [ __ ] holy they're I don't
understand why they can't just adopt a
kid personally and just [ __ ] do it
and then that's it you don't hold it up
on the cover of People magazine look now
I'm agreeing with you I'm gonna go a
little schizo on this one yes Sandra why
do you got to hold the [ __ ] thing up
you know I don't [ __ ] know but she is
doing something about poverty that kid
was [ __ ] broke and I'm really sick of
all you people who don't live in Los
Angeles talking about how plastic LA is
and then you're acting like nobody lies
and nobody's full of [ __ ] in your
[ __ ] hometown just be honest they're
better looking than you they have more
money than you okay and they're living
the life that you fantasize about all
right I'm man enough to admit that I was
actually man enough to
move out here and have the audacity to
think that I could live that life on
some level
let's help a [ __ ] pathetic I am look
I gotta be honest with you if I ever did
something like that I think it's a great
thing to do you know I you know and
considering the world is [ __ ]
overpopulated and where we're headed
towards major food shortages that nobody
wants to deal with because everybody's
you know I haven't had a boy yet so I'm
gonna try to have another kid or I
haven't had a girl yet someone try to
have another kid you know I read
something about this guy in Rolling
Stone today I know his [ __ ] name but
he's some legendary soul singer that
I've never heard of so I don't think
he's that legendary cuz I think I would
have heard about him I think when you're
like seriously little well I guess if he
was an icon I would have heard about him
whatever I'll give it to him he's
legendary the [ __ ] guy had 21 kids
who then spawned 90 grandchildren um and
you know I'm gonna [ __ ] call it first
in the future that's gonna be [ __ ]
considered illegal like what that guy
did is basically he had his own major
[ __ ] oil spill into the ocean but
rather than to the ocean it was on land
you know his [ __ ] semen what just
[ __ ] leaking out 5,000 gallons a
[ __ ] day just like that goddamn
crater the bottom of the ocean you think
he didn't jizz on a couple of ducks
making 21 [ __ ] kids he did that guy
should be in [ __ ] jail for that 21
[ __ ] kids I mean you guys don't work
can you name 21 people you work with can
you imagine if that was your [ __ ] kid
21 kids he has 90 grandchildren there's
no do you understand he doesn't know the
names of all of his grandchildren oh
maybe he does but in order to make room
for that you'd have to forget half your
friends names I know the names of 90
people what the [ __ ] I probably know the
names of 90 professional athletes I'm
really under estimating the power of the
human brain but what the [ __ ]
one [ __ ] guy's dick with two balls as
far as we know created that that [ __ ]
ecological disaster you know what I'd
love about Rolling Stones is is they
they actually got in in that in this
week's issue where they have Keith
Richards on the cover yet again you got
Al of Rolling Stone every [ __ ] three
weeks if they're not to have some teeny
bopper on there they're still mining the
sixties the Exile on Main Street reissue
I love this [ __ ] we're like the original
artists were like back in the day were
just like do you want to release this
song now it sucks compared to the rest
of the [ __ ] and then 40 [ __ ] years
later when you want to buy another yacht
you start putting out [ __ ] that you
didn't feel was worthy of releasing when
you were at your peak you know I don't
[ __ ] that Tupac [ __ ] that Jimi Hendrix
[ __ ] the [ __ ] there's very few that I
can think of that they actually reissued
that were actually worth listening to
I'll tell you one that in recent years
this past decade was led Zeppelin when
they came out with that concert film of
them at Royal Albert Hall and you know
all that concert footage that [ __ ] was
great that actually was great stuff but
they but they also weren't wow I guess
read Led Zeppelin his repackage they act
well what the [ __ ] am I talking about
every two years they they they whatever
ten years they do the new digital
remaster of a whole lot of love you know
what I mean I don't what the [ __ ] I'm
talking about talk about Rolling Stone
okay so getting back to that [ __ ] they
actually do a story on this guy who's
like he goes into like you know war-torn
countries and he like buys up land and
he makes deals with basically war
criminals or whatever to buy up land
because he knows that this unbelievable
like food crisis is coming it's [ __ ]
scary this guy's out there having one
goddamn kids who then go on to have 90
[ __ ] grandchildren and you know that's
the kind of [ __ ] that you know that like
that's a morning talk show stuff you
know like nobody would even even sit
there and talk about how [ __ ]
reprehensible that is I don't know look
I think I should get a tax break at my
[ __ ] age alright I need to be able to
drive a full-size [ __ ] Hummer with no
muffler down the goddamn Street the fact
that I have not procreated and and just
basically you know right now I'm
basically doing what people yeah well
related to Hitler are doing I'm letting
my bloodline die off if you guys ever
heard of that [ __ ] then evidently the
relatives of you know like his [ __ ]
great great grand nephews or whatever or
whatever the [ __ ] they are there's
evidently like two or three more left
they live in Long Island and they all
made a pact not to get married and and
just let the bloodline die off because
they're so afraid that whatever made
Hitler so [ __ ] up will lie I mean
they're talking like some omen [ __ ] you
know like you'd be pushing your little
baby Hitler on a swing and all of a
sudden your nannies
standing on a rooftop you know jumping
off because like subliminally this
little [ __ ] kid told him to with his
[ __ ] up poop Reaper be a prepubescent
mustache yeah I [ __ ] hate this
podcast I really would erase this thing
if I wasn't 35 [ __ ] minutes in I
really would I really would but I can't
cuz I can't I can't go through this
[ __ ] [ __ ] again I can't read this
stuff alright what anyway you know I
can't run what my [ __ ] point was look
I think Sandra Bullock did a good thing
okay
why she did it I don't [ __ ] know okay
but I'm gonna give her the benefit out
that she did a good thing but just
notice anytime anybody does something
even remotely consider it like how
[ __ ] up that makes people around him
at no point did Sandra Bullock oh I did
this you should do this too look what a
great person I am granted she's holding
the [ __ ] kid up like a goddamn
bowling trophy
be on People magazine you know what you
[ __ ] right but I kind of relate to her
cuz like when people find out I died
when I first bought my Prius I got a ton
of [ __ ] from people would you do that
for
what you think you think you're actually
making a difference you know like they
got all [ __ ] defensive I'm like dude
I'm not saying you can't drive what the
[ __ ] you drive I bought it for me I fly
every other [ __ ] weekend I put my own
hole in the [ __ ] ozone layer I'm
trying to do something something you
know to not be a total douche right
that's all I'm doing here I'm not saying
you're doing anything wrong I'm not
saying you can't drive a [ __ ] car
with a v8 I don't give a [ __ ] what you
do get in your car get away from me
[ __ ] [ __ ] um I don't know so
that's what I have to say about that I
don't know if it made any sense I don't
know I got no idea all right uh here we
go bill burr well what do you want to
ask me ask bill oh here's one for you I
got it right here this is the one that's
gonna pull this [ __ ] podcast out of
the goddamn mud bill I'm 21 years old
and attend a Big Ten University I'm not
the best-looking guy in the world but I
think what I lack in that department is
made up with high amounts of
intelligence and charm Wow you just
really sound like a sweaty fat guy with
a lampshade on his head but I'm not
gonna judge
that's another fat guy joke maybe I do
have something with I don't know you
know what it is because I'm constantly
in contact with those [ __ ] people
it's a goddamn epidemic out there you
know I had the aisle seat and I was back
towards the back of the plane today and
you know the aisle seats great you can
stretch out a little bit when you want
to get up and take a leak you don't have
to step over people there's a lot of
[ __ ] advantages to having it but when
you start getting towards the back of
the plane and it becomes that moment
where everybody has to go to the
bathroom and a line develops the problem
is is as these round people are trying
to get past each other there's not
enough room so what ends up happening is
one of these douche bags stomach a slash
unit ends up on your shoulder as they
lean a little bit into your [ __ ]
airspace so the other fatty can get by
him this [ __ ] guy was enormous on the
goddamn plane to the point I felt like
heat coming off of him do you understand
like how out of shape that is it was
like you know you could like like earth
the planet [ __ ] earth how the co its
core is still on fire alright I don't
really didn't want to attack fat people
you know I'm gonna lay off I'm gonna lay
off for the rest of the podcast that's
it
that's it god bless you I know it's a
problem I'm room for you do the right
thing have a salad I got my problems
look at me you know whatever all right
here we go
anyways [ __ ] try to get through this
alright I'm not the best-looking guy but
a little boy can I tell a joke I'm not
just patting myself on the back there
there is a reason I'm stating it alright
for the past two years I've been doing
horribly in school Jesus and I just
trashed this guy he's gonna [ __ ] kill
himself I've been doing horribly in
school dealing with things that are
pretty depressing but because of this
I've had to come up with clever ways of
trying to pass classes in an effort to
not get dropped from school as such my
strategy has been to pick teaching
assistants that are females in order to
try and charm my way into passing the
classes while putting in as little work
as possible as I possibly could dude you
have a future let me tell you this right
now son don't give up on yourself you
have a [ __ ] future if you've figured
out a way to pass classes by doing that
charming people while doing little or no
work I'm telling you there was a corner
office waiting for you so don't don't
give up on yourself all right here we go
what a [ __ ] am i but a little work as
possible granted I am well aware that
manipulating / charming women into
giving me good grades is [ __ ] up and
not the most practical way of going
about doing things but it [ __ ] works
Hey Dude they do that to get a free
drink out of you you don't know if
there's no shame in that fight fire with
fire I'm totally with this guy however
my lack of foresight is very much
evident now is something you probably
saw a coming happened I fell hard for my
ta this the teaching assistant this
semester from day one I was attracted to
her this is a good story so far how
could this go off there
let's continue and while I do try and
charm her every chance I get in an odd
way me being so attracted to to her has
fueled my motivation to study and show
off the fact that I can easily ace her
class I go every week to her office
hours I go to our what I go every week
to her office hours she holds for
students which are about two hours and
nobody ever goes so it ends up just
being her and me flirting with one
another the entire time however maybe
it's because I'm a male or maybe it's
because I'm so attracted to her but I
didn't notice the huge wedding ring on
her finger Oh gah here we go everybody
it's going this way again a lot of guys
out there if I can do on a wrong turn
all right but I didn't notice her huge
wedding ring on her finger up until
about a month ago uh I better in her
class now for about four months I
brought it up to her saying holy [ __ ]
you're married and her response is what
holds my hopes okay before I get into
her response
dude you're full of [ __ ] there's no way
for four [ __ ] months you didn't
notice her [ __ ] wedding ring this is
you toning down the fact that she knew
right out of the gate she was [ __ ]
married she had a huge wedding ring you
didn't notice okay maybe you're young
maybe you don't look but how do you miss
that
and then you said holy [ __ ] you're
married that sounds like a great setup
lying to get the response that you got
so a guy says holy [ __ ] you're married
huh and she go he goes in her response
is what holds up my hopes in an
astonished almost forgetful way she
replies oh yeah Wow okay dude you're in
alright I'm not saying you should do it
but if your if your question is am I in
you are in since this revelation I have
been continuing to bring up as much as I
can about our husband if nothing else
for comparison all right this is getting
twisted dude don't bring up our husband
just go in if you got a bang or just
[ __ ] bang her you know
does he look good better in a jacket
than I do or do I look better the more I
bring it up though the more it seems
like she regrets getting married at such
a young age she got married at 23 now
she's 25 this is my predicament my
parents got divorced when I was six
because my bald childish fat piece of
[ __ ] father cheated on my mother
with her best friend so I have
reservations about dating a married
woman doesn't sound that horrible while
I'm trying to justify doesn't sound that
horrible while I'm trying to justify
attempting to date a married woman but
it's like you said
what is it 75% of marriages go right
down the [ __ ] right now I have no
problem with waiting it out but I'll ask
my question in two forms one what would
you suggest doing to try and feel out
the likelihood of this marriage lasting
and two if it's clear that it's not
which with not much crying done on my
part is clear to see it won't what can I
do to perhaps bring about the break-up
as soon as possible alright dude these
are the questions of a 21 year old okay
first of all you don't date a married
woman all right you want to bang her go
ahead and bang her she actually wants
you to bang her because she needs some
sort of spark to get up her courage to
get out of that [ __ ] marriage that
she clearly didn't want to be and I'm
telling you right now as as she was
walking down the aisle her brain was
screaming what the [ __ ] are you doing
alright this is a you know she got
married at 23 I don't know what her
dating experience was before that maybe
she doesn't know how to get out of this
she seems like someone who does not know
how to get out of a relationship now
what kind of relationship she has it
doesn't sound like an abusive one it
sounds like I don't know she just got
involved in something and then she just
got into deep didn't know how to get out
of it the dude had met her family when
he get married and she just [ __ ] went
down that [ __ ] waterslide she didn't
know how to get off and now this is her
deal so this is the deal dude you're
going about this the wrong way I first
of all you shouldn't [ __ ] do it
alright you shouldn't do it
because you're dealing with the married
[ __ ] woman here there's somebody who
wanted to spend the rest of his life
with her all right
and you're delving into that [ __ ] so you
know and hi right now dude you don't
know what this girl's gonna do okay she
could be using you for the courage right
go out and [ __ ] bang you all right in
a goddamn rainstorm come home like a
drowned [ __ ] rat just so he can start
the conversation be like honey where the
[ __ ] have you been so she can just flip
out and be like I just [ __ ] one of my
students you know just so she can just
get out whatever how many [ __ ] years
she's been sitting on I don't want to be
with you anymore
all right and I'm telling you if you if
you meet a psycho [ __ ] woman they
have a really bad [ __ ] habit of doing
something really [ __ ] up with the
person that they're in a relationship
with and then they feel guilty
afterwards so they have to confess and
then you know the guy can't hit the
woman so guess who he's gonna come and
hit you know that you just blew up his
[ __ ] life so you shouldn't [ __ ] this
girl but I'm telling you right now dude
if you're gonna bang her just [ __ ]
bang her
but you wanting to date a married
[ __ ] woman it's completely the wrong
[ __ ] thing to do I think I just gave
you the green light to go ahead and bang
her if you want you know I mean I'm not
telling you to do that but I'm telling
if you gonna choose one of the other if
you got three choices don't [ __ ] her
that's what I'm telling you to do all
right but if you're gonna go with if
you're gonna go to the dark side
there's Darth Vader and there's Darth
Vader light here okay
and I'm saying it to take the the less
calories of evil here what you should do
is just try to bang her do not try to
date this girl okay this girl isn't
ready to date she doesn't know what the
[ __ ] she wants she shall she so doesn't
know what she wants and she show her so
has an inability to communicate what it
is that she wants that she actually
married somebody she doesn't want to be
married to she's just sitting there with
it's screaming inside I
don't wanna maybe married you I don't
wanna be married I don't even married at
this point in my life I don't wanna have
kids I'm not ready for this I want to
get the [ __ ] out of here I wanna I want
it that you know what she needs to
she's break up with this guy and go get
an apartment and live by herself for a
good year and a half two [ __ ] years
you know and not really date anybody for
a good six [ __ ] months cry this [ __ ]
out go to therapy figure out what's
wrong with her
make a [ __ ] list of what she wants in
life she's got to do [ __ ] she needs to
do that kind of work and you're trying
to date this woman this [ __ ] mess
while she's still married don't do it
all right go charm the [ __ ] out of
somebody else and and try and bang them
I'm telling you right now dude don't
[ __ ] do it don't do it all right
that's my advice to you that's it that's
it that's all I gotta say on that don't
don't [ __ ] bang her and if you do
decide to bang her I mean it do decide
to get what they do not [ __ ] dater
okay even even if I'm telling you dude
you're gonna [ __ ] probably make the
wrong decision because you're young
you're probably gonna try and date her
cuz she actually got feelings for all
right and then what she's gonna do is
she's just gonna use you to get over
this other guy before she dumps you and
[ __ ] rips your heart out of your
goddamn chest that's what you're gonna
be roadkill all right
fortunately you haven't banged her yet
you know all you got is feelings for so
get out now dial it down a sir class get
on with your [ __ ] life there's plenty
of other [ __ ] teacher's assistants
out there that you can bang all right
but that's that's not the move to make
good luck to you it's your life you make
your decisions but I'm telling you over
and over again evidently I'm gonna keep
saying the same thing over and over
again do not cease and desist [ __ ] that
walk away walk dude you know you don't
want that on your resume you just don't
all right all right trust me okay here
we go
asbill ah this story is a little bit
long but without the clothes oh Jesus
here's another one oh Jesus
[Music]
the story's a bit long but in the end of
your podcast but in the end oh this is
this is actually an interesting one here
okay bill this story's a bit long but in
the end your podcast makes a girl cry
okay somehow my podcast made a girl cry
okay here we go I was out with a close
friend and his girlfriend his girlfriend
having some drinks and five bottles of
wine later my friend's girl brings up a
point about how pro athletes are
overpaid I said yes it is dumb to pay
someone eight million dollars to catch a
football but if you think about
everything else it's it's it is deserved
first off millions of people plant plan
their every Sunday around watching these
athletes and since the industry is a
gold mine for the owners the talent gets
paid a pretty fair portion secondly
virtually every man in America has
played organized sports at some point in
their lives I think it's fair that you
are if you are the absolute best at
something that every man has tried to do
in their lives you should get paid this
isn't the high score and that arcade
game and your favorite pub every man in
America has put put some quarters in
this in this one I don't know I think
that was some of that left out or did I
just read that bad anyway so I'm from
that it quickly turned into an argument
about the fact that Pro women don't get
paid that much and that's where I bowed
out I stopped and said oh you're one of
those girls I'm sorry but this
conversation never goes well
Jesus dude you're totally baiting her
for a fight I love this guy
okay she snapped back and said no no no
say what you're gonna say no come on you
brought it up [ __ ] say it
she didn't say all that but I know she
did so he goes honestly I tried to avoid
the issue no you didn't you baited her
into it by saying oh you're one of those
girls I'm sorry but this conversation
never goes well
classic what do they call that we had
you [ __ ] yet you do the reverse sell
yeah you don't want a car like this then
the the the the guy actually sells it
himself oh there's my dog Cleo come over
here Cleo do what's going on
I just picked her up she was staying
down at the doggy super8 look at you
they gave you a little high-top fade
didn't you trimmed underneath the belly
huh
what's up buddy Aleksei onto the
microphone all right here we go
I [ __ ] hate when a dog does that lick
my [ __ ] toes weird it's a creepy
[ __ ] moment that should not happen
between an animal and a human being
all right I'm continuing on yes he
basically you baited this one into a
fight dude you know you did I know you
did and I love you for it I think it's
great
I love arguing with women like this too
so when he was let's continue on and I'm
not buying your [ __ ] honestly I tried to
back out but she said say what you gonna
say so he goes honestly I tried to avoid
the issue I did I will say that I am a
bit of a massage a misogynist yeah okay
yeah dude okay I had no idea but I know
uh what not to get into with feminists
plus she's my friend's girl
this is getting ugly and you're drinking
this cannot end well but she forced me
into the argument after she heard me say
after she heard me say to my friend why
am i arguing with the girl about sports
dude you're being totally
passive-aggressive that's hilarious
let me guess you said it like three feet
from her ear why am i arguing with the
girl about sports I mean they don't know
[ __ ] about sports you know why don't
they just make me a sandwich and then
they [ __ ] they come back at you and
you and you act like you know I tried to
avoid it okay here we go
so it began it began here's the argument
she told me I played high school soccer
so I know sports this made me snap
because she was bringing up high school
credits to me which people really don't
do around me people don't do that around
me I guess for good reason in high
school I was ranked number one in the
state for three different sports ranked
nationally in football I was inducted
into the high school football hall of
fame at the age of 21 played Division
one ball on a full scholarship and was
projected to go seventh in the draft
until I blew me knee out I gotta ask you
a question dude blue meanie out
are you from like England were you
playing footy we talk in soccer over
there at this point I thought you were
like maybe that that guy that [ __ ]
running back there that went to Buffalo
from Ohio State
um no but he did he did go number one in
the first round didn't he when he
pretended to talk on his cell phone to a
team but he was really talking to his
agent the [ __ ] was that guy's name
anyways um I don't Willis McGahee
all right continue bill fine I don't
bring this stuff up ever so she she
might not have known but she baited me
and I felt like putting her in her place
I was starting to get arrogant but still
making my point so you're basically
telling her that you would rank number
one in three different sports and you
would have been 7th in the draft but you
blew out your knee dude I wish I was
there to see that that's a great one I
bet that shut her down uh but she baited
me and I felt like putting her in a
place I was starting to get arrogant no
not you dude you down to earth but still
making my point of why sports are such a
money-grabber
I said over 60,000 people come out every
Saturday to well over 60,000 people came
out every Saturday to watch what me and
my friends do athletically and we
weren't even getting paid she
interrupted with I don't care that she
started talking about women's soccer
again so I interrupted her by saying I
have never played soccer in my life but
I can guarantee you that I am better at
it than you are
dude will you blue you like leaning over
a table of Coronas pointing in her face
at this at this point and are you much
bigger than her of her [ __ ] boyfriend
that he didn't try to step in oh god I
wish you [ __ ] me this would have been
a great YouTube video anyways now what I
meant by that was I was probably twice
as fast five times stronger and have
enough natural coordination to pick up
soccer and be as good if not better at
it than you because I'm a pretty high
level athlete what she heard was all men
are better at sports than ever then
every woman she got emotional
but her anger held back the tears while
I was just trying to figure out while I
just trying to figure out how the
conversation got to this point well if
you want to figure out how it got to
that point let's start with your opening
line of like oh you're one of those
women I know enough not to get into
arguing with the [ __ ] woman like you
you know come on dude you baited her
into it
you baited her into it you wanted to
have the argument because you loved
yelling at women and I relate I'm not
judging you
um you know it's not like you're on a
People magazine holding up the woman
that you were yelling at cuz you just
adopted her like Sandra Bullock look
what I did awesome yay she got emotional
but I ain't gonna held back on tears
well I'm up and up and uh finally my
friends stepped in and I settled down
she just she got silent for a bit but
she sparked back up when I brought up Ed
Hardy shirts the ones that are so
colorful and bedazzled and worn a couple
of sizes too small by dudes she said I
don't got it I don't get my guys wear
stuff like that girls don't like girls
don't like it I came back as I came back
and said as before I agree that the
shirts are dumb but girls actually do
love that [ __ ] dude you just love
[ __ ] pissing off women that's what
you do you're just arguing with this
woman on every [ __ ] point that's what
you're doing and I think it's [ __ ]
hilarious because I've done this I am
this guy did I write this that I get
drunk and send myself a [ __ ] email
anyways she replied with are you gonna
tell me that you know more about girls
than I do too
then I do also basically he said to
which I said yes and he finally admits I
think I was trying to fight at this
point we were on bottle seven of wine I
said you obviously know more about what
it's like to be a woman sorry my screen
just went blank you obviously know what
it's like to be a woman than me yeah but
figuring out what girls want in a man is
our job as guys since I was 14 I've been
studying this [ __ ] I spent more time
learning about girls in college than I
did about my about my degree
she made some more dumb points mostly
just angry at me saying well I don't
like the shirts and I'm I'm a girl so
there you go anyways you know how when
you drunk you get better at arguing but
Merce worse at making coming up with
solid points I couldn't think of how to
explain this to her but a classic bill
bill burr line came into my head I told
her you don't get it men literally have
to develop a skill to get women to like
them and then he writes which is a great
line by the way but I may have taken it
too far and he goes on to say it's not
love at first sight in all that
soulmates [ __ ] men have to purposely
take steps to get you separate they to
separate yourself from the crowd the
feelings part the feelings part might be
out of your hands but to set up those
things isn't easy unless you're wearing
some sparkly shirt most of my closest
friends wear those shirts and trust me
it works I'm not saying you're stupid
I may have said that part a little
sarcastically course you were but let's
pretend that me and my friends have only
let's pretend that me and my friends
have only slept with 50 girls each that
means I personally witnessed why over
300 girls have slept with guys plus add
up all the times we all stuck we all
struck out and why I think I'm pretty
experienced in knowing what girls like
how many girls have have you convinced
to [ __ ] you this is when she cried what
I didn't know was she used to be a
lesbian she quit being a lesbian to be
with my friend and she is sensitive
about it yeah I would think she would be
sensitive about it considering you can't
quit being a lesbian you either are one
or you aren't one yeah you know I kind
of blew a couple of guys but I quit yeah
I didn't like it made me paranoid went
back to vet Chinese anyways he said I
became at that point I became the
[ __ ]
I left the bar thinking two things one
why did half the [ __ ] I said come out
with a Boston [ __ ] accent and after
realizing this
after realizing the reason why I thought
[ __ ] I gotta stop listening to the
goddamn podcast can you believe this
[ __ ] guy I mean there must have been
22 off-ramps he could have taken as that
thing developed into a major fight and
he chose to stay on the highway and then
in the end he comes around and he tries
to [ __ ] blame me
dude the reason why you listen to this
podcast is because you just like me not
because I've created a me inside of you
all right the [ __ ] dude come on admit it
you like doing it I like doing it I love
him women go in there and they and they
make some stupid [ __ ] statement I
love at that point I love thrashing them
because so many guys just stand there
and they just they just sit there and
agree and they let them say stupid
[ __ ] things with no points behind it
because they're they're still in that
adolescent keep it happy maybe it'll
[ __ ] me and it gets annoying and you
just sit there and you watch one guy
after another getting played for free
[ __ ] drinks you know carry and [ __ ]
for them helping them to move and it
makes you [ __ ] annoyed after a while
makes you annoyed but and then what you
do is you get involved in [ __ ] like that
and you absolutely bury him let me ask
you this dude how many times it how many
times were you [ __ ] standing up
pointing at her huh be honest you know
you even alluded to it yourself will you
just sitting there going like maybe I
said that a little sarcastically a
course you did of course you did
you know whatever do you know if you
[ __ ] yeah you got issues with women
so do I welcome [ __ ] join the goddamn
Club don't blame me don't [ __ ] blame
me go find out where the meeting is and
then tell me where I can go with like a
couple of guys with with drinking
problems so if you find out
don't you think what you did was that
bad
I don't think it justifies [ __ ]
crying either I think that whole thing
is annoying you know what I'm gonna stop
this podcast here cuz it's already been
over a [ __ ] hour and I know by the
end of this I'm gonna end up agreeing
with this [ __ ] guy which I don't want
to do because this guy is
I'd say about 18 months ago I've
actually made some strides haven't I
Clio right I got a female dog didn't I I
got a [ __ ] laying at my feet
[Laughter]
alright whatever there you go another
jet-lagged podcast everybody
congratulations to Philadelphia Flyers
I'm [ __ ] pulling for you guys it
could be great to see you guys win a
championship or even the [ __ ] Eastern
Conference Finals God knows you'd be
you'd be more better behaved than those
[ __ ] up in Montreal who burned down
their [ __ ] City every time they win
and then they look down on us because
we're fat [ __ ] at least we don't like
[ __ ] on fire you [ __ ] pyromaniacs
granted we dumped because so many of us
are so flammable because of all that
[ __ ] lard we have inside of us only
night with that man with the fetch you
okay like that people get hurt this week
all right that's the podcast god bless
alia and I will I'll talk to you next
week
[Music]
[Applause]
you